what i want to do in this video is
clarify some of the notation that i've
been using in regards to regressions and
in particular we're going to focus on
the difference between the sample
regression and a population regression
just to think about that
so let me draw
let me draw
a
some data points and just for fun let's
make it a little bit more real world
let's say that each of these points
represent
how much on the x-axis will say how much
a stock index changed so let's say that
this is this is change in the x-axis
percent change
percent change in
in the s p
s p 500 and let's say on the y axis on
the y axis over here i have the percent
change
percent change
in
the price of
ibm
in ibm stock so let's say on one day
when the snp let me give a let me mark
this up a little bit so let's say that
this is
one percent two percent three percent
this is one percent two percent three
percent and then this is negative one
percent negative two negative three
stocks obviously can go down this is
negative one negative two negative three
for the change in ibm so just to make it
clear what we're talking about so let's
say one day the s p 500 goes up by one
percent and on that same day ibm goes up
two percent so we'll mark that point
right over there and then on another day
the s p 500 goes up two percent and ibm
also goes up two percent
and then another day it goes up maybe
one and a half percent and maybe ibm
only goes up half percent and so you
could imagine and then another day let's
say the s p 500 goes down two percent
and ibm goes down three percent
maybe there's even a day that the s p
500 went down but the ib but ibm stock
went up so maybe it's right over here
maybe ibm reported some good news
despite the rest of the market being
down and maybe there's a couple of days
where the s p went up but ibm went down
because it just maybe there was some bad
news and i'll just throw some other
points here i think you get the general
idea
every one of these points represent a
day where we have the percent change in
ibm
relative to the percent change in the s
p 500
so what would we do here so this is a
sample these are samples
each of these
each of these are
samples
are samples
of
of i guess we could call it the random
of the random or they represent
they represent samples of the random
variables
of the random variables x
and y and let me define what x and y are
where x
x is
x is equal to the percent change
in
the s p 500 s p 500 and y
and y
is equal to the percent change
the percent change in the share price of
ibm
these are both so this is just a sample
of it so if we wanted to do a regression
line we've seen this before what we
would do is we would find the sample
mean of both of these variables just
based on these n samples here we would
find and we would also find the means of
their product and also the mean of the x
squared and we would come up with a
regression line
we'll come up with a regression line
that has some slope and some y-intercept
so let me draw a regression line here
maybe it looks something like this
let me make it so
it intersects
so it has a noticeable y-intercept so
maybe our regression line looks like
this
and this is where i want to make the
clarification i call this regression
line y is equal to m
x
plus b because it has some slope m and
it has some y-intercept b this right
here is b
but what i want to clarify right here is
that this regression line is an estimate
of the true regression line between the
random variables if we just kept
sampling if we just kept sampling more
and more data maybe our regression line
would change right we can take an
infinite as long as
ibm and the s p 500 exist for all of
time there might be an infinite number
of samples you can just keep adding
samples over here and getting a better
and better regression line so when you
only have n data points you're taking a
sample of the random variables and
that's why we use this notation
we'll say that this is an estimate of
the true slope of the regression between
x and y and this is an estimate of the
true y-intercept between for the
regression of the variables of x and y
and then we can very clearly use the
formulas we've been using that m
that m
is equal to
the mean
of the products
of each xy coordinate the product
minus
the mean of x the mean of the x's times
the mean of the y's
all of that over
all of that over
the mean of the x squareds
minus
the mean of x
minus the mean of x squared this is the
notation this is the formula that you've
seen in several videos right now but i
want to make it clear since we are
dealing with a sample this is the
notation for sample means this is giving
an
estimate that's what that hat means it
means it's an estimate of the true slope
and of course the y-intercept here
the y-intercept here we're going to get
b
b is equal to let me write it this way
we know that we know from early videos
so we have this formula right over here
and we know that the point the mean of x
and the mean of y is on this line right
over here so you just have to solve for
b so our estimate of b
our estimate
of b of the true regression line the y
intercept of the true regression line is
going to be equal to
the mean of the y's i could even write
it i could write it like this the mean
of the y's
minus
whatever we solve for over here minus
our estimate of the slope times the mean
of the x's
that right there so remember this is
just we're estimating this is the the
best regression for our n data points
for our n samples now if we keep doing
this in theory if we did it forever
there's some theoretical line here
there's some theoretical line here that
is the true regression line if we were
to just sample an infinite number of
samples or as long as these two exist
maybe they exist for the next 500 years
and so we have you know several hundred
thousands of samples maybe there's some
true regression line that looks more
like this
i don't know there's some true
regression line for those two random
variables and just to show you the
difference between this this kind of
estimate of the true regression line
right over here and the true one let me
write a formula for that so if we call
that y is equal to
mx
mx plus b here we'll say that m
is equal to and now we're assuming this
is the true line now we're assuming that
we know the true parameters for these
random variables we don't just have to
deal with these statistic these
statistics these estimates we know the
true parameters and so we can say that m
is going to be instead of the mean of x
y it's going to be the expected value
the expected value of
x y of the product of x y
minus the expected value of x
times the expected value of y so these
are the true parameters for these random
variables
all of that over
the expected value
the expected value of x squared
minus
minus the expected value of x minus the
expected value of x squared and then if
you want to find the true y-intercept if
you really knew these parameters it
would be equal to
the expected value
of y
minus
this m right over here minus m times the
expected value times the expected value
of
x now just to make sure that we
completely understand notations and all
of that if we think of these as if if we
think if if there's a finite population
if there's a true population here
then we can even write it this way and
there are equivalent ways to write it we
could write that m
the true slope of the true regression
line is equal to the mean
the mean
of the product of x and y
minus the mean
of x
times the mean
of
the y's
all of that over
the mean
of x squared minus the mean of x
minus the mean of x squared if you view
these if if there was some finite
population then you could say hey here's
the mean right over here or actually if
i guess some infinite as long as there
is a mean which is really the same thing
as the expected value then you could use
either of these and of course the b here
is just going to be equal to the mean
of the y's minus whatever you solve for
here minus m times the mean of the x's
now you can imagine that this is
functionally equivalent to this
if you if if these data points actually
represent the population if the if your
sample if you sampled the entire
population then each of these things the
mean of the product of x and y is going
to be the true population mean so in
general it won't affect how you're going
to do most regressions and when you're
doing most regressions you're going to
get n data points it's all you know
you're not going to ever have infinite
data points you're going to have n data
points
and then you're going to just solve for
the mean of the product of your x and
y's minus the mean of the x times the
mean of y so on and so forth anyway
hopefully that clarifies things a little
bit